today's topic now listen while i am
sympathizing with what's going on in
ukraine i understand that what they've
been dealing with is absolutely wrong um
there have been calls now from not only
the ukrainian president but a lot of
folks in north america within the eu who
are saying that we need to go to war
with russia and put
boots on the ground okay and let me be
the first to say i am absolutely against
any of these ideas i don't know if you
guys feel the same as me but with all
the issues that we have going on in our
own country i'm always sick of them
having to spend tax dollars and billions
of billion dollars to send
people we know people we care about
overseas to fight in other countries am
i the only one who's just like i'm out
of this um i was thinking about that
[ __ ] when i got out of the cadets and i
was like [ __ ] i'm not going to military
and i'm saying i thought to myself hmm
uh maybe not because there was a movie
that came out with will smith it was
about muhammad ali yeah and they were
talking about the fact that he didn't go
to war because yo i'm not going to they
did nothing to me and i was thinking i
was thinking um they did nothing to me
i'm not gonna go fight a war and get
hurt and get injured and uh people are
not like i'm not gonna have the help
that i want or i need uh when i get back
uh i got a friend unfortunately he was a
medic and he was a civilian medic and it
was a medic in the water as well okay
you went to afghanistan ptsd okay yeah
and now we can't work uh it's [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] so did i want to go through
that um
not really how about give you another
one it's like breath they don't even
take care of the veterans who come back
from these spaces yeah they don't even
take care of the people that are all the
on all these disabilities yeah they
don't want to use a tax dollar for that
but they're ready to use tax dollars to
fund a new war yeah right they don't
want to use tag dogs to take care of
their own people the ones who are
disenfranchised the ones who have all
these issues the ones who are drowning
the students but they want to spend
billions and billions of dollars to send
folks overseas again to fight more wars
creating more orphans creating more
widows creating more issues and i'm like
breath at what point
are we gonna learn this lesson listen i
understand it's complicated it's a
serious situation but i'm so sick of
like so quickly being like we gotta sit
why you know what i'm saying like what
is the reason and if you feel strongly
about this and you want to go to ukraine
and defend the country shout outs to you
go ahead right i saw a couple dudes from
the uk who went to go i got no problem
if you want to put your own life that's
your own choice but how many times are
we going to always be sending this money
away hey you know what i'm saying thank
you very much for your service when you
come back and i'll give you like a
couple of bucks in your empty coffee cup
because you can't work and [ __ ] because
your [ __ ] is all [ __ ] up
over all that stuff people were like
when you think unless get the [ __ ] out
of here you bugging you bugging it's one
thing to defend your home it's one thing
to defend your home okay and if the
cause makes enough sense okay i can
understand it but it's like they don't
want to take care of what's happening at
home but they want to go and put other
people's houses in order
i'm not with that no i understand the
issue is is serious and i think it
should be handled in ways that make
sense but putting foot on the ground
starting a new world of wars like bruh
you guys are bugging straight bugging
it's weird it's weird they want to do
they're ready they're not only ready
they're excited you wanna know why
because defense contractors know they're
about to make bank
they about to make bank right the same
way it's like lawyers always win in a
divorce doesn't matter whether their
client wins or not they always win yeah
this is the same type of thing yeah it
doesn't matter they're getting paid
money they're getting paid
uh well it's too bad you you didn't you
didn't win what do you mean we aren't
you representing me oh no [ __ ]
i won
this is not even gonna be a long video
i'm just not with it i don't want to say
that i don't care what nobody says
i don't care what nobody says you don't
support no [ __ ]
stay in your ass home in fact if we
would have done that a lot of countries
would have been way better off today
ain't no [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] don't
even lie about anymore yeah we know you
know we
it was for though and people just
admitted no but we needed that oil i was
like damn
uh did you drive your car
shut the [ __ ] up